If I was a rational person,
I would have dropped out of
this race a long time ago.
Crowley hasn't had a primary
challenger in 14 years.
He has taken $3,000,000
per cycle.
He's gonna tell me I'm small,
that I'm young,
that I'm inexperienced.
My mom cleaned houses
growing up.
I never really saw myself
going into politics.
Americans aren't asking
for a lot.
They're asking for politicians
to help them get by.
-I can do this.
-I know you can.
We're doing something
very controversial.
People say, "How dare you
mount a challenge
to someone
who is so established?"
It's not just our family.
It's 30,000 families a year
losing loved ones because
they don't have insurance.
I was not trying
to become an activist.
I live six minutes
from Ferguson.
Being a woman of color,
our image is scrutinized.
People in my district,
this is how we look.
I come from a long line
of coal miners.
We've been collateral damage.
They underestimate us.
I'm running because
everyday Americans
deserve to be represented
by everyday Americans.
I'm not going to allow
my daughter
to have died for nothing.
The problems we have in our
district, we ourselves can fix.
I get scared of the cynicism
from people
really believing in something
and then it not working out.
I just don't want to
let them down.
You have to be fearless,
or they're going to
come after you.
Nobody owns you yet.
No matter what the outcome,
it will never be the same.
We're going to fight
for each other.
Some of us
have got to get through.
It's about the whole movement.